bonjour à José Espinosa merci d'être
nouveau samedi de mobilisation et
plusieurs objectifs aujourd'hui
oui il y a plusieurs objectifs mais
enfin ce sont des objectifs que nous
avons depuis longtemps
développer le pouvoir d'achat
[Musique]
remettre en place l'impôt sur la fortune
démocratiser fortement
et
[Musique]
effectivement
c'est quand même un moyen de
aujourd'hui donc oui
comment dire mouvement qui s'élargit sur
toutes ces questions et qui ont
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
rapidement maintenant je ne pense pas
qu'avec ce gouvernement les choses les
choses dans ce sens
depuis le début de ce mouvement
[Musique]
sur l'énergie évidemment
alors que nous sommes en plein 5e comme
le gouvernement a dit que le plan blanc
et est activé dans pas mal de régions
est-ce que ça nous freine pas un peu
dans votre élan
mais non mais le problème c'est pas le
faire le problème c'est de développer
une politique de santé qui répondent aux
questions posées par exemple des
fermetures de lit dans les hôpitaux
continue en plein pandémie c'est
incroyable
[Musique]
et
des éléments contradictoire sujet du
vaccin puisque le vaccin protège un peu
mais pas totalement c'est-à-dire donc on
est toujours victime de cette pandémie
qu'on soit vacciné ou pas par contre le
pas sanitaire c'est un élément pour
empêcher des gens de pouvoir vivre
normalement et en même temps c'est les
obliger à se vacciner alors
personnellement moi je suis vacciné mais
je sais qu'il y a des gens qui veulent
pas se faire vacciner c'est leur choix
il faut laisser la Liberté à chacun
se comporter comme il en tant
que c'est pour le bien commun